now imagine a single trap which you can
apply from both the colors
and it is such a powerful that you can
win many of your Blitz Games with some
nice attacking ideas
sounds very interesting right
welcome guys as in today's lecture
we are going to see a double trouble
which arises from two different openings
yet contain same venomous trap
[Music]
okay
obviously let's start with the white
first
we are looking at the Tennyson Gambit
model
so if you are a E4 player then after D5
you play Knight to F3
gambiting the iPhone
and rather than this I strongly insist
you to play the Moon Knight to F3
as if you look at the database D far is
by far the most popular choice and after
this what else
of a wonderful Denison Gambit with E4
okay black took it and after Knight to
G5 black has two choices to hold on to
his material
but it doesn't matter to us so let's say
Knight to F6 is the most popular one
and here
more than 10 years back I have created a
video
starting with D3 an original version of
the Tennyson Gambit however the modern
Theory suggests that white should
continue with Knight to C3 a tricky
approach
where obviously white has renewed the
threat on e4
well recently in one of my bullet game
my 2200 plus rated opponent continue
with IFA which is as per the database
played in roughly 20 000 Plus
leeches games
but I'm afraid just one move Bishop to
C4
and suddenly black is having some huge
problem on the F7 Square
so note E5 is right out of the equation
black should defend the spawn with
Bishop to F5 and here the funds start
with this very fast development of
pieces
Bishop to C4 attacking on F7 black has
to play E6
and now rather than playing the move
Queen to E2 and trying to get the pawn
back
I strongly insist you to continue with
F3
which again has an idea of regaining the
pawn bag
and considering what black has played so
far if you really want to get the pawn
Advantage then he has to take it which
is of course the Top Choice from the
database
whereafter Queen takes F3 we set some
the first platform for our upcoming high
profile trap where white has two threads
number one everybody will see that B7 is
dropping but number two a crafty one and
that is Knight to F7
which is unfortunately missed by even
strong players
so the most frequent response is Knight
to C6 addressing the one issue but
falling right into White's amazing trap
and that is awesome
a superb sacrifice of peace
and the big point is when black take it
you come in with Queen capture the F5
thanks to the pin epon where not only
white get all of his material back but
the big time factor is now black has a
weak Pawn situated on the e-file where
his King is wide open for the attack
okay if you look at the database here
Knight to D4 is by far the most popular
choice the idea is very obvious
black is defending the pawn attacking
the queen as well as looking at the
juicy C2 Square
surprisingly and funny enough if you
turn on the engine here engine suggests
that Queen S3
allowing black to take on C2 but in that
case black king get checkmated
so you can see that line in the PGM
however if black doesn't take on C2 then
it is bit complicated
so rather than going for that I am going
to suggest white should continue with
Queen to D3 and defending all black
threats
well our idea is very obvious we either
want to play Knight to E2 and C3
dislodging this Knight or if black
continue with the most popular choice
namely Bishop to C5
stopping our Castle then white can
continue with Knight to E4 not only
attacking this bishop but the threat is
Knight to G5
so more or less black has to take it but
then when white recapture
once again we have a simple plan
and that is
after Rook to E8
planning to siphon the black king
white can continue with C3
Night Moves then you attack the bishop
and when finally all of the black pieces
become passive it's time to take on H7
and if you look at this position
not only white is a clear Pawn up but
look at black king it has been
pathetically placed and if I turn on
engine
well guess what it says it is completely
winning for the white
so this is one of the high profile trap
exist in the modern Tunisian Gambit
which you can definitely employ in your
Blitz and the bullet game with a very
good success ratio
okay it's time for the reverse color
with the same trap
and that occurs in the Budapest defense
which goes as follow D4 Knight to F6 C4
and now our thematic idea e far
where this time around white has an
extra Tempo with C4
so this can be a nice tactical weapon
against a player who is playing this D4
C4 openings
okay white has to take it
and let's see if you can find the same
continuation which we have seen from the
white side
fast move Knight to G4 attacking on E5
it doesn't matter how wave and white
defense let's say Knight to F3
do you remember the next move
yup Knight to C6
once again renewing the thread
so white has to defend with Bishop to F4
and the most important feature is if you
look at the database Bishop to B4 has
been exclusively played here
but not
we are looking for something very
special and that is Bishop to C5
same old story
we are forcing white to play E3 and
after that
nope not Queen E7 but the golden break
yup you indeed remember F6
and after this what else if white wants
to hang on to his Pawn then he has to
take on F6
but after Queen takes F6
look at this position guys
same what we have seen from the white
side
and time and time again
we have a double threat and many many
white players has failed to Spot It
okay it's time to check database Knight
to C3 Top Choice
but congratulations to wide as this
straight away fallen into our trap and
what else this nasty night sacrifice
gives black a completely upper hand
well now the sequence is very obvious
King takes F2
Queen takes F4
and after Knight to D5 do you remember
what to do congratulations if you find
the move Queen to D6
which Parry all the threat and now
thanks to the White open King and weak
Pawn on E3 this position really favors
the black
well to finish up the video I like to
show you my quickest win in this line
where my 2100 plus rated opponent
continue with some obvious moves and
still cannot hold the defeat
Bishop to D3 happened planning to do the
artificial chasm
I continue with castle and after Rook to
even
the nice move Knight to E5 create some
huge problems
number one black is threatening Knight
captures F3 and ripping open the white
king and number two Knight to G4
which also create the more pressure on
the E3 Pawn
well my opponent didn't like the idea
that he has to give up the light Square
Bishop
so he played Bishop to E2
second most popular choice from the
database
but just two moves and wide position is
completely falling apart
did you find it
congratulations if you see the sequence
Knight to G4 check ing to jivan and now
the sting in the tale
Queen to F6
where black has a double thread number
one attacking on E3 number two very
important sacking the rook and
checkmating wide on the S2 Square
obviously now white cannot handle all of
this pressure and in the game my
opponent choose the move S3 which turn
out as a big time disaster as after
Bishop takes E3 Knight takes E3 and
queen takes E3
he find elegant movement to resign the
game in the view of
King cannot go to effen as Queen to F2
is a Checkmate and if King goes to the
H1 Square then after Knight to F2 white
sweetie disappear from the boom and in
fact the game
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful trap from both the
colors
and remember the Tactical pattern which
I have shown in both of this line that
is when white try to defend his B2 he
straight away fallen into this nasty
night sacrifice
whereupon King takes and queen takes a
fool
whitegate horrible Pawn with the open
King
and no wonder in the Blitz this sort of
trap walks like a charm
well best of luck for trying your own
game
and feel free to like subscribe and
comment here I'll see you in my next
episode very soon
bye and take care